[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
à
que ce soit le pen au bâton alors c'est
pas la même chose du tout mais dans les
deux cas dans les deux cas sa finale est
logique à sortir un rapport tandis qu'on
a trois en voiture j'ai des choses
16h35 voilà
donc que fait l objet de manifester
parce que si on fait rien bah c'est de
vivre il s'agirait
d' arrêter en fait de penser que la
démocratie ça c'est seulement dans les
journaux d'accord il ya une élection
présidentielle il ya eu onze candidats
la gauche a recueilli 32 % des voix au
total et on a le droit d'être
insatisfait par les résultats de cette
élection d'autant que les 18 25 ans
votent à 33% pour jean luc mélenchon
au second tour les qualifie c'est un
acte un timbre homme de droite et marine
le pen car programme d'extrême droite et
c'est pas des programmes qui ne
respectent pas les étudiants on a publié
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de faire
entendre nos voix
[Applaudissements]